hello and welcome to a spectator
discussion
on one of the most important perhaps the
most important
topic in britain today what has just
happened to our children's education
how deep is the damage and how can we
repair it
we're also going to be looking at the
role that online learning can play
in making up the lost ground and i'd
like to thank our sponsor everfi which
is an education company offering courses
in things like financial and digital
literacy health and
well-being we're going to be hearing
from some of the most articulate and
influential divorce
voices in this debate from robert
halfron tory mp and chair of the
education select committee
from ann longfield who only last month
stepped down as children's commissioner
from adrian packer whose education
principal with core
education trust which sponsors academy
schools under its own
distinctive learning style and finally
martin finn who heads up global
operations
mfi uk and now we're going to be
um taking opening remarks from our
panelists i'll be asking them questions
but importantly
we're going to be taking questions from
you watching this
now you can submit questions by writing
in the text box of our website
or if you want to be old school you can
email events
at spectator.co.uk
there is so much to discuss so many
questions to ask so do
please fire in the questions whenever
and they
strike you you'll be able to watch this
whole panel again by
pressing replay after the event
so first some um opening comments
and roberts uh let's start with you
thank you and that's really uh great to
be doing the spectator platform thank
you for all you do
for education um i just want to pose the
question what
are online learning actually
mean we've seen the oak national academy
bbc bite size the national tutoring
program google classroom the invicta
national academy but to be clear all
these things are
absolutely welcome
i worry that we are focusing uh too much
on
inputs as opposed to outcomes i think
that
a lot of the chatter and talk about
online learning has a bit being like the
old practice production in the soviet
union has gone up by
x percent but whether or not the people
had any grain
um is a different story and
we've asked questions like how many
children don't have laptops how many
don't have wi-fi how many laptops have
the
bfe delivered what about 4g routers how
many views has the
oak national academy got and all these
things are important but
online learning can't be an argument
about the numbers going into the machine
because even if the government doled out
millions of devices
even if the oak academy went viral do we
know
they're making a difference what impact
are they having do we know if the
children have the motivation to switch
them on and concentrate
without the usual support networks
available in school
and we don't and so we should be looking
at online learning
in terms of outcomes
and there doesn't seem to be enough
being asked in my view as to the actual
impact these initiatives are having on
children's attainment
in my view there should every child
having gone back to school should be
assessed
by the government to look at the schools
and local authorities to look at how
much lost learning there's been and how
much backed up is needed
and there should be regular assessments
given what has occurred
um as well but we also need the right
kind of
online learning so if technology is used
to purely digitalize
what would normally be done in the
classroom i.e
streaming an otherwise unmodified lesson
or submitting homework through virtual
learning environments rather than in
person
then we can't expect great leaps in
terms of efficiently recovering
lost learning although we might save a
fair wack of paper
we need to be efficient with catch up
because if we do move at a glacial pace
we'll allow the pandemic to have
a rear shear effect damaging the life
chances of the kobe generation year
after year
and if children don't catch up quickly
they'll struggle to keep pace as they
progress to the next academic year key
stage or
college and university and we know that
the pace of capture will be different
for each people
due to different experiences in in
lockdown and often
have highlighted just how children's
knowledge base and soft skills have
declined
offstead saying children had been
disoriented anxious less confident with
others slowed
join in with activities nfer
eef study in autumn found year two
pupils were two months behind in english
math and maths compared to the pupils in
previous years
and the department's own study of
northern term suggested that
uh schools with high levels of
disadvantage have experienced higher
levels of loss in other schools
particularly at secondary level we also
know bc before corona virus
that disadvantaged people to 18 months
plus behind their better off peers by
the time
they sat their gcses and that hasn't
altered despite all government reforms
for five years
and in 2019 nearly quarter of all
vacancies
were skills shortage uh vacant there's
an increase of two percentage points
on 2017 and nine million adults in
england have low literacy or new mood
skills
so the numeracy skills so the mammoth
task recovery demands a much more
sophisticated
approach and this is where we can really
harness advances
in technology through the use of ai
artificial intelligence
the taylor learning i know there are
many ai skeptics who see it as snake oil
but if we remain always remain stuck in
the past refusing to look at any
advances in technology
we'd still have the team train instead
of the bullet strain
uh the the a3z rather than google maps
and the penny farthing instead of the
pelican
bike and there's the central tech
founder and winner of the spectators
national innovation of the year award
priya lakani notes in her 2020 book
inadequate he says delivery of education
has not fundamentally
changed its industrial revolution we've
gone from a backboard to an interactive
whiteboard
and not much further i would struck
recently when a princess trust young
ambassador told me she was a kinesthetic
learner
i regret to say that i wasn't aware if i
was in
inter or intrapersonal learner if i
learned best ordered poor release
spatially or verbally
or a mixture of all these but i'm not
sure i'm alone
in that ai online learning can learn how
each child absorbs information best and
tailor the content
optimize learning for that individual
it's like having a 24
7 personal tutor on your desk and to be
clear this is not an attack on standards
ai can work alongside a strong focus on
academic
excellence and zero tolerance approach
to poor behavior
the remarkable michaelis school as i
understand it has harnessed technology
to monitor
the effort students put into their
assignment while schools were closed
so this is where i um go back to the
central
uh question um can online learning help
recover what children lost during
the pandemic i really believe that the
best kind of learning takes place
inside school gates because the home
environment doesn't lend itself to
focused learning laptop
or no laptop the nhs has a
10-year plan why can't education have a
long-term plan
and the pandemic's thrown up all kind of
questions about our education system
should we all determine times extend the
school day
change the curriculum scrap gcses
replace a levels with an international
employers at 18.
my favorite option is to extend the
school day supported by civil society
groups
provide extracurricular sports mental
health and academic catch up
where needed now extended hours and ed
tech
should be eight and it's something the
education recovery saw
could be considered particularly as we
march headlong
into the fourth industrial revolution
pwc suggests that 28
of jobs done by young people at risk of
automation or ai and understanding the
potential disruption that the rise of
artificial intelligence and automation
will cause
is crucial for establishing our
education system to respond and that's
why i believe we should
establish if possible at short and
snappy world pension on artificial
intelligence
made up of the finest practitioners but
also experts in ai data and learning
economics and education to understand
the impact
that ai is going to have and inform a
national long-term plan for education
so in conclusion we need to know what
we're talking about when we say online
learning
we must do much more to focus on
outcomes rather than inputs
we need the right kind of catch up and
be efficient with our recovery efforts
does not damage the perfect generation
for years to come
it means harnessing ai as a personal
tutor on your desk
online learning should take place in
school and it must form part of a
national long-term plan
for education which may involve
reimagining our whole education system
and assessment and we must understand
the impact of the fourth industrial
revolution
and adapt our education system to meet
those challenges
thank you thanks very much robert lots
of food for
thought there and i would like to go to
ann longfield dan was
as being children's commissioner for
many years and way before it was
fashionable to do so
she was campaigning almost as soon as
lockdown started for it to
flag up the problems that the absence of
classroom learning
would create so she spent the last year
over many years
as children's commissioner campaigning
for education
and over to you thank you and thank you
uh
for inviting me to this um event and
i think um you know we have spent many
of us on the screen
robert especially uh the last year
arguing that schools are a good thing
which is something i never imagined that
i would
have to do um this notion that actually
kids should be in school and school
had benefits and actually benefits
beyond the classroom was something which
i think
this year has taught us um
but i also think it's been a year where
there's been that kind of
really sharp spotlight on to what the
experience
of going to school and education is for
kids and of course like every other
aspect of their lives we now
know if we didn't before that it's very
varied um
the difference for the kids over the
last year
that have been in you know comfortable
houses with parents that are working at
home
with those that have been in cramped
accommodation
um sometimes with parents who needed to
go to work has also been
reflected in their experience of school
you've had
some kids that would be largely going to
private schools that have continued
almost from day one
with the full classroom online um
you know logging into each classroom um
working throughout the day
and certainly for the first lockdown
there were a huge amount of children
that didn't have access to either the
tech
or indeed the broadband um and
there's an estimate of about a million
children
somewhat more than that possibly who
haven't had tech
um for large parts of this or haven't
have it in the household
and when we talk about um online
learning um
and i think or agree completing what
robert just said then about online
learning
um but also for online learning for a
lot of kids certainly at the beginning
of lockdown
was the phone and sometimes it was a
borrowed phone from a parent
and sometimes it was a broken phone with
a cracked screen so this notion that
actually
um you know the fact that children are
working online even if they can get on
isn't always what we think about in
terms of that kind of um
you know um really intense study that we
want children to be able
to do um or even intense experience so
i think we know an awful lot at the end
of this year more than we did um
at the beginning but also we do know
that digital has taken on a new
centrality in terms of children's
learning and you know over the years our
children's commission i've struck really
early on how kids told me
that actually you know in their minds
the digital world was just part of life
you know it wasn't this thing that you
dialed up like some of us remember doing
um it they couldn't see where the
different parts of their life
started and ended and i think there's
something there that wasn't the case 10
years ago that is the case now
which does demand that we look again at
how we can use
the online experience in a whole range
of things
including um education um
i think it's really important that we
look at what
the place schools are in terms of their
own
tech and we know again that um uh the
experience in private schools about 60
of them already
set and had education
online um compared to about a quarter of
state schools
slightly more state schools in affluent
areas about a third of them
but the starting point for a lot of
schools was hugely
buried um in some schools they were used
to setting homework online
many many others weren't and a lot of
the connection with more vulnerable
communities over the first few weeks and
months
was really about keeping in touch you
know in in a physical way
visiting the house handing out papers
and packs
um you know almost something which is um
for most people several decades out of
day
um but i think there is a moment now
where
we can really revolutionize
the role of schools uh and in digital
education but i think we're going to
have to want to do it
i would love to see schools being really
brought up to have
the best tech possible in terms of uh
children's learning
but also to look at how schools can
become digital hubs for that wider
community um you know we know there's
lots of ambitions around broadband that
government have well let's start with
schools
let's look at how we can make schools at
the forefront
of uh the digital um revolution
including
um and for first and foremost with
education
um i think the gains for that with
children are enormous
gains in terms of enrichment and in
terms of uh supporting their wider
education
uh gains in terms of their particular
interests or even needs we know that
actually um mental health support online
it's been something that kids really
took to during
the last year we didn't know whether
they would but actually most
do um but also in terms of getting kids
ready to work and really ensuring that
those children
who we know need the greatest resilience
in terms of any economic downturn
or recession that's coming have the work
skills that they need something i think
we often take for granted but something
if you've been using digital
uh your way ahead off more
than others the two things that
and slightly reflecting what robert said
the two things i'd really like to
um just make is a little bit more wary
of first of all
about 40 of the uh lowest income
households said they didn't have
desk space for their kids to learn at
the beginning um
of lockdown um so again you know we can
make as much available digitally and
give as much takeout as we want but
children live within households and we
should be aware of what that means in
the past
there was a big push to open schools for
actually
homework um at various points i'd say
i'd want social activities as well but
you know we need to
understand that that's not always the
case um
and then the other is about just
personal interaction i saw what happened
in some universities around
going on to a digital basis whereas kids
often lost that interaction or
could lose that interaction with their
tutors with that relationship and i
think it's very easy for some kids
to fall out of that but i am a normal
optimist with this
i do think there is a potential here and
i think that something now in terms of
the wider debate about
not only buildback but also getting
ahead and leveling up this really does
have a place
and um thanks very much um for that now
i'd like to
turn to adrian and adrian perhaps you
could just say a little bit
about about core and and what it does
but then tell us about your marks yeah
so we are a multi academy trust we
sponsor schools uh but we specialize
in looking after schools that have
had some difficulties and challenges
particularly uh reputationally
when things have gone wrong so we put
things
right so we're very used to dealing with
complex situations
uh not quite at this level but um we're
certainly
adept at crisis management and we have a
very outward facing approach
and we work in partnership with uh
sports physical activity
and arts organizations uh to enrich the
experience that we give our children
in in the schools that we sponsor
so um is that is that that answer your
question
yeah yes absolutely no just because you
know quite often
it is easier for for schools with very
affluent very rich families back at home
to adopt online learning i just wanted
to say before your remarks that
the the people you're dealing with are
the ones at the sharp end of the
problems we've just been discussing
absolutely and they are not hard to
reach and this is something i'm always
emphasizing we
we use that expression far too easily
that these children hard to reach and
actually to
to robert's point um it's easy actually
easier than we thought to distribute
laptops that's the easy bit
it's what happens once those laptops are
are in the homes
of the families we're looking after and
that does require
a lot more thought i think we've just
focused on coverage on the idea of
distribution of of of equipment that
that scratches the surface of the real
issues but but also it loses sight of
the potential of technology
kovid didn't invent technology in
schools
we were using technology before the
pandemic and
of course we will use it afterwards what
it's done is it's it's focused our minds
on the potential
of of of technology but but i think as a
frontline practitioner i i
one thing i want to do is is to
encourage us to stop using
defeatist language of gaps and general
left behindedness
which which that does affect the
children we look after but that's not
what they want to hear that's not what
they need to hear
i think we need to shift the debate for
all schools but particularly for
in my context we need to talk about
acceleration
we need to think about potential of this
reimagined future that we're all talking
about but i think we should be
talking about that future as a period of
restoration and that that should give us
real hope for the future so just just
briefly on on
to take an analog perspective for a
moment on acceleration
yes to shorter holidays and to longer
school days
absolutely yes uh 39 of
english community sports facilities are
behind school gates
so let's get them open and often
and now let's i want us to have a real
focus
on sport physical activity and the arts
i i think we used to call
it youth services but but i think as as
part of this reboot
um i don't want these these really
important endeavors to get lost within
the
discussion and debate around around
technology
um and i also think we should be
expecting teachers to fix everything
we might open the schools but they they
don't need to to be there to deliver
uh every aspect of provision in an
extended day
so we know there are thousands of
external qualified providers
and they're out there ready to get back
to work and and to offer
a decent supplementary provision
and then on potential and this is being
touched on by everybody
it's really thinking of schools as
places of congregation and safety
and that's what we found with our
vulnerable children they have certainly
become more vulnerable
our at-risk children have certainly
become more at risk
so we know and we should absolutely
celebrate the schools provide
a canvas to to to be safe and and to
learn about themselves
uh and others and let's face it we
should be talking about what we've all
missed most and that's just
just being with each other so i think
this idea
of congregation is really important so
being
online together is one thing but being
physically together is another and we
must not lose sight of that and that's
not just the classroom by the way
that's the playground the school hall
and the corridors i i really
love the story of paul mccartney meeting
george harrison
on the school bus on the school bus
and it's fascinating when you think but
they didn't actually do brilliantly in
their music lessons
in fact they did pretty badly and they
were probably just too busy dreaming of
a day when they'd meet john who who went
to the college next door
but school for them was a place to meet
and to dream and i don't think we should
ever apologize for that
so on restoration and that's where the
technology comes in
i think and and everyone's already kind
of touched on this idea of the what next
the debate about what next and that
being a long term what next
please please a long term what next
i don't want us to put all our academic
catch-up eggs in one basket i think we
should look at
um this this necessary innovation
through adversity
to become plain and simple reform which
will allow us to look forward with with
a high degree of optimism so i want us
to be bold that's my view as
a frontline practitioner and i do want
to look at the purpose and function of
external exams
and i do want to look at the richness of
technology as well as not
instead of and and they might be seen as
as hot potatoes i i
i don't know those two issues of exams
and technology but
there is no doubt of course they've been
thrust upon us as a result of the
pandemic
but my feeling is this what if we looked
back
and realized we'd actually stumbled upon
a long-term solution of greatness
that's what i'm hoping for the future
isn't cancelled
in fact it might actually end up looking
better than we could
ever have imagined uh by it being
reimagined
i suppose and i know you may say
i'm a dreamer but you know the rest
well let's see if you are the only one
adrian and
mark martin finn we've heard a lot of
very interesting perspectives there um
about the potential of tech about the
limitations
of online learning about whether we
might have stumbled
across a magic solution so please let us
have your perspective
on what we've learned and what we've yet
to learn from the last year
okay um so thanks thanks fraser um look
first
i i just want to extend a little bit
about what we do at ever5 because it
very much sort of informs what i'm going
to say
so we use education and technology to
address a range of
social challenges in the uk and globally
and we do this by delivering teaching
and learning programs to
schools but on behalf of businesses
government and charities and we help
them engage with schools
and young people and bring their
expertise and those
real world examples into the classroom
learning so as a kind of shorthand is
that
we bring business and education together
so there were three
points that i was going to to make in
relation to this and and
the first is really about that learning
gap um
adrian apologies for using that that
word but the learning gap and
i think that we must look at that gap
beyond just academic
terms and about providing that rounded
education for all young people because
what we've seen ever far interestingly
has been asked of us
most during this pandemic is about
topics such as work related learning
and health and wellness and
entrepreneurship and i think also that
the
array of issues that we've seen arisen
from the pandemic and the biggest one of
those is mental health
but also about those development of
social skills and about that ability to
work together
about development of language and i know
others have mentioned other things
that they've highlighted just how much
schools
deliver way beyond the core academic
understanding
and i think a really important point is
that all of those issues have affected
disadvantaged children
disproportionately
in the pandemic so that they've got even
further
to um to catch up than some of their
more advantaged peers so i think we've
got a gap on top of a gap
so my my second point is is about what
role technology can play in this and i
think we've just had the largest
experiment in the use of educational
technology that we have ever seen
one of the things is i hope that there
is going to be a huge
data gathering activity to pull together
the learning from that to find out
what's worked
and what's worked for some children why
it hasn't worked for others
and and how what we need to take forward
going
forward um but the evidence points to
the fact that the teachers what they're
saying is
they're going to use that technology
much more in their teaching in future
and by this we're talking about teaching
and learning technology not about the
zooms in the teams and also that
students want to learn
using that technology more in future but
if we're going to do that and if we're
going to close that gap
equitably and robert i take all your
points about
we need to focus on outcomes but i think
we need to
um ensure that all students have access
to a computer at home because some of
that learning is still going to be
happening at home
and we're talking about computers not
about one mobile or one device
between a large family i think that they
need a computer to access that
or they're going to be disadvantaged but
i think what the pandemic has
has also shown us is about it i think
it's reasserted the primacy of the role
of the teacher
and what teachers um have schools have
told us
is just about how what students want is
that time with their teachers and it's
just about how important that
teacher teacher-student relationship is
so what
technology can do to help with that is
that it can free up the teacher
to focus on that people support focus on
those relationships and that teaching
that face-to-face teaching
but leave some of that where technology
can deliver some of that that
um subject matter teaching and if it's
right it should be directed by the
teacher it should be evidence-based
and ideally it should be feeding back to
the teacher so that they know
what uh progress the pupils are making
and that's where i think technology can
can really score in helping to address
this issue
certainly in in that shorter term
and the the final point i want to make
is um
is about just the i think the monumental
task that schools have got and it's one
that's going to to last for years
and i think that they can't do it alone
and
so while there are all sorts of other
outside providers i i think it's also
time that businesses who aren't engaged
with school
and education that wherever possible
they need to come forward and see what
they can offer
and they can help with in sort of so
many ways whether they're small
or large particularly around i think the
non-core learning with things like work
experience around financial literacy
careers awareness and health and
well-being and i think all of these
things we would say that all children
should have access to them
but also that disadvantaged children
will have the least access to those
without that support
from other organizations including
businesses and that's why i think now is
is the time that some of those
businesses need to
to step forward if they can so i think
those are the
the three points that i would make to as
some opening remarks about the issue
martin thanks very much indeed now i was
going to do my questions but we've had
so many questions coming in
from people watching this that i'll go
straight into them
just as a reminder to ask a question you
can ask it either in the text box if
you're watching this
online or by emailing events plural
at spectator dot co dot uk that's events
at spectator
dot co dot uk now we've had three
questions on the same theme to you
robert halford because
in some parts of your opening remarks
you sounded quite pessimistic
about the about the the notion of that
of
what it can do now nobody i think would
seriously dispute
but the best learning takes place inside
the classroom
but i guess the question here is if you
want to do educational catch-up for
example robert you've spoken about
extending the school day now you might
get your way but if you don't
then the only two will have in our
resources will be electronic tools
but you mentioned artificial
intelligence uh
can you say a bit more about what you
mean by ai in the context of education
you seem to be optimistic
about ai and contrast it with um lower
forms of online learning
yeah well first of all i'm not
pessimistic about uh
online learning i i love technology i
absolutely think it has a central
a part to play and absolutely every
child who
can't get access to a mobile phone or
pop a computer needs to have one i see
that in my constituency where
families are using one three-year-old
four-year-old phone
mobile phone for you know four or five
people
and i also think the online learning
experience
has been very good for many students you
know you've bought the
existing establishment national
established national tutoring program
you've also got disruptors like the
invicta academy that are doing
a lot of good things but make what i was
trying to say was that first of all i
don't
i think a lot of focus has been about
inputs computers how many hits
websites have had and we don't know yet
which is the best
uh best products and terms of the
um catch up all the evidence shows and
i'm not
necessarily talking about summer
holidays here because
obviously you want the disadvantaged
peoples to go and the evidence suggests
that actually disadvantaged people don't
always go
to summer school activities and so on
all the evidence shows
that i have seen that a longer school
day with
predominantly mental health activities
well-being sporting activities
makes a huge difference to the
educational attainment of children both
in terms of numeracy
general education payment increasing by
up to
uh two months and my focus if i had the
option of extended school day would be
to focus on predominantly
sporting a mental health well-being
given what has occurred but also
possibly academic
online catch up but at school i want the
children to be
at school so the points that adrian made
were
quite remarkable and absolutely right
because the children
go to school to socialize to form
networks
some of them get fed because they don't
get a proper meal at home they get
counseling they get support
if they come from very troubled families
we've got to get away from this idea
that
children children can do everything at
home of course some can and there are
many great home educators but we need
our children
back in school and doing those online
activities in the school
in terms of the ai what i'm talking
about are the programs that you
literally
the the student will have a computer or
tablet on their desk
and it whilst the teacher is teaching it
reflects the learning experience
of those what i've seen it reflects the
learning
experience of that student and adapts in
a way that the teacher is not always
able to do because obviously the teacher
is teaching to
a whole class of people with very
different abilities and
the way i uh i start bi is very simple
it's like having
a super chess computer type personal
tutor on your desk
if i can just if i can just interrupt
you there are you saying that the
devices you're talking about are
actually
asking me people's questions are they
testing them throughout the lesson how
they're supposed to find out how well or
otherwise this
student's learning central tech i
mentioned who won your award
uh is kind of some of the leaders in
this but there are many companies and we
need to look at what works but
they're doing a mixture what i've seen
they do a mixture of everything they ask
the students questions they adapt to
their learning they pick
uh their learning uh mechanisms which
you know if a teacher is teaching 30 35
people with different abilities they're
not always
able to uh to do that and i think the
potential could be very very exciting if
it's done properly if it's tested
if the outcomes of the students are
clear because we have to make a
distinction as i say between
what i call the snake oil salesmen and
the genuine
innovators who can really make a
difference right
um adrian a question here from
um nick watson he's asking
if you mentioned that you can give kids
computers but it's whether they use them
at home
that is the difference or not in other
words they'll be um you know
some kids sitting there with their with
their mummy even their nanny who knows
standing over them saying
yeah you're going to make sure you use
this lesson then you're going to get
other kids you don't have that parental
attention
attention perhaps not that neglect but
perhaps
the mother is working or whatever what
can be done
if anything to help those children
because if you're relying on online
learning
um the question is are you not
fundamentally um
there's not much you can do to reach out
to a child you can't see because he's at
home so
so i guess the next two questions what
can you what can be done
for the pupils you feel are falling
behind in the way that you've outlined
and secondly how do you know if they're
falling
behind the first things we've already i
think we've already answered the first
question is is get children back to
school
home is home school is school it's a
from my experience it doesn't really
matter what kind of home you're talking
about it's it's still not school
we need children in school they are
let's let's hope they stay there
uh and let's let's uh promote all the
ideas we've talked about already but
you should probably join that i don't
think that you know for this discussion
you're right schools are back hopefully
they won't be disrupted
again everybody agrees that the
classroom is best
the questions whether when you're doing
catch-up whether it be evenings weekends
summer or whatever
in that context that's when online
learning comes to the fore
and i asked the question here was how
can
you you tell if you are going to i don't
know if you have any plans to continue
online learning when schools are back
but if you were to
uh how do you spot kids who are falling
behind okay so
so this is also this relates to the
point i made earlier which
is we were using technology before the
pandemic we are we are used to using
technology to enrich
and complement uh in-person learning um
this idea of going back to the defeatist
language of falling behind
undoubtedly uh disadvantaged children
all children have have had a period
where they will have fallen behind
and i think how we measure this is quite
complex
because we can look at academic
data of how they're falling behind but
it's very difficult to measure
how they're falling behind because they
haven't had the opportunities for
for the kind of things i talked about
the physical interaction and and i think
we will continue to learn about that
over time
but on the idea that the extended day
the holidays and everything else i have
slightly different experience to to what
robert explained on the
on the evidence that um there wasn't a
massive take-up on
on summer holidays we have incredible
take-up when we
we offer a decent provision and maybe
that's the issue it's decent provision
and and and i can relate that also back
to technology which is
i don't think any of us are talking here
about technology for technology's sake
we're talking about using technology as
a way to
enrich the experience that we're giving
our children and to make it more
efficient
i i love the point that robert made let
teachers focus on on the business of
teaching
and let's look at how other aspects of
the job
might be picked up through technology
through ai potentially i've seen some
really good examples of that
so this is looking at it holistically in
the round of of
technology being part of a much bigger
reimagining
of what is possible uh so i i i don't
think we should we should get too
hung up on the idea of um how how do we
know how far behind children
are of course we know we know that's a
problem but
we should be focusing on how do we
accelerate
opportunities for all children in as
many different ways as possible and
technology is part of that
martin finn can i ask you to comment
about ai as part of
online learning i'm not quite sure if
that's a funny way of saying
like online learning which does more um
regular
assessments of people's progress is this
a growing part of of um of the scene of
the industry if you can call it that
yeah i think it is a growing part of the
scene and i think there's a lot of
technology out there that
some which has has been around for a
while um i think what i think there are
there are sort of two issues really i
think for me about the short
the shorter term and the longer term and
i think what robert's talking about
for me feels like more like the longer
term and and i think that
technology is only going to develop and
it's only going to get
smarter but even at the moment i think
there is a lot of evidence-based
technology that is there and where it's
properly designed and it's well designed
it's looking at what the student does
it's giving students options so that
they can
direct some of their learning it's
gathering data as they go
it's allowing students to gather
what they want to do as they go through
that learning journey and it's feeding
back to the teacher
and i think if that if that is robust
and
if that is well designed and it's
properly done then
that plays a huge role in terms of
supporting the teacher to allow them to
do some of that face-to-face work that
adrian's been
talking about that and i'm not
suggesting also that all of this
learning should be happening at home
i think it's part of that school mix but
i think that the reality is that we have
to
understand where schools are in terms of
their use of technology
and where teachers are in terms of their
confidence with the use of that
technology
and there are there are they are at so
many different stages
and that we need to build on uh what
schools have learned
during this uh during this pandemic and
we
also we need to be gathering that
because we have such a sort of dispersed
school system that uh there is there
aren't those sort of obvious sources
of of that data gathering to find out
actually what's worked and what hasn't
and then we need to apply that but we
also need that longer term plan i think
that robert was talking about
with those much more advanced
technologies and and they need to be
proved i think before that they're you
know they can be properly introduced
right and log field a question for you
and
we're hearing about every new or not
exactly
new but no newly used potential of
technology to identify who's falling
behind and the kids who need extra help
a question from nigel minizumi and
you've been children's commissioner for
for several years you were for several
years
and why is it taking a virus to make
government think
about what home internet provision can
do for disadvantaged children
yeah well um i mean it has been quite a
shock i think this last year on
many many fronts and different aspects
of all our lives but children as well
and um some of these issues about the
way
uh children learn um and the need for
technology
i don't think have been at the forefront
um and
it's been this year i think the fact
that there was no alternative
suddenly children weren't in school um
and you know the number of days they've
been out accounts for about 850 million
in total so a massive number
of days that kids have been out but i
mean certainly
i for one have been um arguing for
um uh what i call holiday play schemes
we call them summer schools we call them
whatever we want
um and after school activities and
actually before
school activities since well from
virtually
the first month i actually gained
employment so
you know some of these things come
around and
seems to me uh that we need a logical um
uh uh solution here it's not just
suddenly about kids
you know actually doing all their
learning um online at home
it's actually how they can combine this
within their time now hopefully
in school for the long term and
i think that um you know what we're
talking about here is ways
of making children want to learn there's
something you know children
children learn best when they want to
children actually go to activities they
want to go to
the drawers got to be in there for them
to be able to do that
and want to do that so i think there is
a another
interesting angle here which is about
how do we make
the learn how do we how do we enrich the
learning process
and make it appeal available for
appealing for children
who we're asking to do more of and i
would like more i'd like more
time in school i'd like more extended
days uh
and holiday activities very broad social
activities play
sport arts and the like and some
learning with that too
but i'd also like them to be at the
forefront of technology because we all
know what that can do
with our lives if we want to learn a
language we go online as adults if we
want to
um you know find out about a whole range
of things we go online
so i don't want children to miss out on
this because it's too difficult
to do in a math system which is quite
disparate
and that i think is where we are at the
moment with schools and
tech at a very different place for
different schools that's something that
i think the only government can step in
to help
boost to ensure people get to the same
place or a good place
okay thank you man a question from james
macpherson to
adrian and in your experience as a
principal he's asking
have you noticed any new um computer
products any new digital learning things
things that made you
think maybe halfway through the pandemic
wow this is quite good i hadn't quite
thought about the potential
of this particular software as a
learning tool i guess
the question is if you've seen this as a
catalyst for innovation or a catalyst
for um for teachers thinking about how
online learning could help and perhaps
they in a way they wouldn't have before
the pandemic
now i've been quite disappointed we
haven't innovated more
i think we've we've lost the opportunity
to this point
we've it's been very much that um
it uses a mechanism to to maintain a
form of learning
and i think we've we've been in a
kind of survival mode i i think what
should happen next is we should start to
look at technology
in a a thriving mode of of of innovation
i suppose that's what i'm saying is this
is a moment in time to
to really uh kickstart that innovation
around looking at a technology beyond
a team's lesson so what are things you
have in mind i mean
when you're giving us the sort of the
john lennon optimistic scenario
could you give us some could you imagine
as it were and
some sort of tech which which might help
you in your dream scenario
yeah i've seen some examples of the ai
um i
i've not i've not seen it in a in a
school's context
and i think it's that next step that
next leap towards
what does it actually look like that we
need to encourage
but you see the problem we have in in in
schools in general is that we're we're
we're sometimes frightened of innovation
because we think we're going to get told
off
and how do we create more safety around
the idea of of
introducing some of these ideas um and i
think that's where
we just need to create a more
collaborative approach
and a sense of oneness around where we
all want to fix this together we can all
innovate together so i think we should
be encouraging that ambition
for innovation and yes technology
absolutely
we talk about it as though it's not part
of children's lives it's a huge part of
children's lives
we've just got to i think do a better
job of working out how we harness it
in a school's context without uh
compromising on all the other
okay a question em to you martin finn
from omar malik
and everfi is a global company are there
any countries
which you see doing online learning
better than others who've handled
the sort of digitization during the
pandemic of education better than others
yeah i think i think it's a really
interesting question because i think the
one of the interesting things about the
pandemic is that schools right
across the world have all been affected
in exactly the same way
um and certainly sort of governments
have responded to it in
in different ways and i know for
instance there was a big um experiment
in chile where with with the um
which the government actually incredibly
quickly
gathered together expert online classes
that were then distributed through
a very large swathe of schools and um
uh and also you know in many very
deprived
circumstances so i think there are
examples in lots of different countries
that you can look at developed and less
developed
where the technology has been used but
obviously it also goes back to
whether or not children have had access
to those devices and some of the
programs that we've had
which were being delivered on online in
some countries have no longer been able
to be delivered because
children just don't have from home they
have the access um
you know to to the the technology so i'm
i'm not sure that i think i know of
any country that has singly has sort of
handled it
brilliantly but i think there's also you
know many of these technologies go right
across the globe
and that they're they're available to
schools you know in
in any country and in multiple languages
and so again
i'd go back to this point that we've had
such an experiment
we must now look at what has actually
learned
and how we therefore reimagine the
schools and i think what adrian was
talking about reimagining that school
and i think some of that is about
reimagining um how that whole day works
i think it's reimagining how the
technology is used at different parts of
that day
and also if we're going to go into
extended schools and
and look at sort of a different um
sort of tone of learning in some of
those spaces
how we can use technology to best effect
because one thing that is
absolutely clear is that young people
like technology
they like engaging with it and i think
one thing that we haven't talked about
is that we also need to ask children
what they want going forward
and what they've found most useful
during this period and
what technology has actually worked for
them individually
because i think that that will also
determine about how we can use it to
best effect
going forward right um roberts
um we as a spectator we had a cover
story written by a teacher a few months
ago
and she was saying that her problem and
experience of with them online
and learning was that the kids when she
was in school she works for a pretty
tough comprehensive
the kids that she was least worried
about were the ones who filled in their
homework
quickly and accurately but the ones
people she was worrying about from from
day one
were the ones she thinks did not a
sausage in her words during lockdown
they basically
weren't engaging there wasn't anything
she could do about it
now you spoke about the education gap
being wide enough before the pandemic
i put it to you that your government is
in no rush
to assess the damage done here that you
there could be
national assessments conducted to find
out what sort of pupils
have them have suffered most during
lockdown how far behind they are
but there seems to be a little bit of a
senior evil approach from the government
and
also from the opposition both of these
parties backed locked down
neither of those parties seem to be in a
rush to have a stark look
at the implications of lockdown and the
educational damage
so might you have a bit of a battle on
your hands simply trying to draw
attention
to the extent of the problems when it
comes to the widening
of inequalities in the era of of remote
learning
well this is why i've argued that we
need a national long-term
plan for education a
a recovery plan um because um
the damage that has been done
particularly this disadvantage you've
highlighted ihyalis and many others have
highlighted particularly the children's
uh uh previous children's commissioner
now
um i'd also as i say i think them i mean
i know that they are
probably using consultancies to find out
about lost learning but i think there
has to be some kind of
national assessment for um for
every child to find out exactly how much
lost learning there has been
and then you work out what the catch-up
is
needed and this needs to be this needs
to be
done pretty quickly it should have been
done uh last year and it should be
predominantly to every student i think
that the government needs to look in
long-term
about the pupil premium how that spent
should it be more focused for long-term
disadvantaged pupils rather than just
those on preschool meals over six years
because they dip in and out some
some of the families um this is why i'm
arguing about the school day as well
because
i absolutely believe that some
activities should go ahead and
i'm sure brilliant schools are enticing
parents in but the advantage of a long
school day is the children already there
they don't you don't have to drag them
in and
i think all those things um need to be
considered but the primal
priority of the government should
absolutely be and
you should we should at least
acknowledge the 1.7 billion packed up
one which is money that didn't exist
some months ago
but nevertheless the priority has to be
to reduce
uh the the learning gap between
disadvantaged pupils and they're better
off
here's and absolutely we might have to
be very careful about language i had
parents saying to me
very good parents who are campaigning
that they don't like the words catch up
and left behind because they see it as
very stigmatizing their
kid so language and narrative um needs
to be important but i'd like the prime
minister to literally
get up in in downing street and make
that
speak about a national long-term plan
for us to produce a white paper so
you give education staff stability and
to really
have a whole central focus of that plan
to be focusing on
reducing the uh reducing the attainment
down
right as much of interest but
quick excuse my mom was a special needs
teacher i mean every
language which you use here catch up
special needs hard to reach
it can become stigmatizing is there
language which
you think would make it less so because
what we're trying to convey is a really
important concept that some children are
simply going to need
more remedial support than others i mean
even the word remedial can seem to be
majority who have used in their own
terms so
so what should we be doing here to to
discuss the mission ahead of us
well i think positive i think um agent
used the word acceleration
and moving forward and we should i mean
i i'm as guilty as anyone
of using the terms catch up and left by
the whole myth is doing an inquiry at
the moment into
left behind white working blast boys and
girls who are
more disadvantaged in almost any other
ethnic group or cohort in
education and do the worst every stage
or education system but we need to
frame the language the language is
incredibly important i'm not an expert
in that but
in a positive way that doesn't
stigmatize but nevertheless
does what it says on the tin and make
sure these children
get back on that education ladder of
opportunity
okay thank you and logfield when you
were children's commissioner one of your
superpowers as it were
was that you could ask data from any
organization that you wanted to think
i'm writing saying
i have to say as a data geek i would
absolutely love to have that that power
even for a week
the information i would ask for but um
because this is the great mystery now i
mean
we started off this by asking what is
the extent of the damage we don't really
know
i'm wondering what information you think
needs to be
needs to come to the fore now so we can
work out what to do next because
if we're not frank about the nature of
the problem we're not going to be very
successful
in dealing with that problem and you
will know perhaps
better than the most people what sort of
information is available
and what is obtainable i don't know if
you can use
it maybe to come up with a national
nationwide pupil survey to try to
to try to get an assessment of this but
what's your thoughts on the
questions that need to be asked now yes
well certainly that was
one of the um you know most powerful
tools
that you have in that role is you can
collect that information and certainly
over the last year i've really been
saying very often to government that
they need to be collecting that
information now
they do collect a lot more information
now than they did
at the beginning of this pandemic but it
tends to be information about
institutions about schools being open
about schools
school days all of those things was
actually it needs to be about
real people's lives it needs to be about
what children
assessments about children's learning it
needs to be about
children's mental health it needs to be
um about
you know the number of times children go
to a e
um now this isn't some kind of big
brother um
you can still do this without names and
addresses but um
understanding what is going on in
children's lives because one of the big
things that
doesn't happen which needs to happen is
that actually across
government the mission of government is
to help children actually
flourish um and that doesn't happen
because each department takes it into
its own particular kind of um
lens and looks at it from their point of
view
so i would say yes her children being
back in school but what's happening to
children with special educational needs
yes about the uh about children's
progress and
any gap apologies for that um
but really understanding children's
lives i think the other part of it
is when children fall out of school um
if children aren't attending if they are
being excluded because obviously
those are bad signs and a sign that
something
else is needed i'd also like it'd be
wider understanding how many children
are living in poverty because only once
you have and not just the overall
numbers but you know which children and
for what circumstance because only once
you have that data
can you start working out not only what
to do about it but
modeling scenarios such as recessions
before
they come along and be prepared for
those
um uh for those situations to hit with
the policies that are needed um
all of those things obviously i'd say
are really important but at the end of
the day
it comes down to will you want you need
to want to do this
and you need to want to make the kind of
long-term changes and plan
which um you know we're all saying uh is
absolutely needed
thanks um another question here from
mary kernick cook
um does initial teacher training include
learning to teach digitally now unless
there are two mary kernick cooks out
there i doubt it this is the former head
of ucas so
um it's great to have you with us mary
and and
and any i'll throw a question to any
panelist does
initial teacher training include
learning how to teach digitally good
question
anyone know i don't know the answer can
i just say one thing on teacher
equipment you know we know that
two-thirds of new teachers leave the
profession after five years
and part of a recovery plan or long-term
plan
should be about transforming teacher
equipment incentivizing teachers to work
in disadvantaged areas perhaps setting
up
local teacher training agencies or
recruitment
uh colleges in those areas
to get um good leadership good teachers
where um the schools need it need it
most
right well i'll give you something to
cheer you up robert mr spectator
recently tried to hire a teacher she's
one of her former interns but she
wouldn't join us because she's loving
teaching too much
so that's good news um it's probably you
know i've mixed feelings in that i felt
sad as a potential employer but happy
for society that women are for caliber
are are staying you know to be honest
where they can do the most benefits um
but um but
training on teach training that of
course uh
we again it comes back to this point
that this isn't this isn't new to
teaching the idea of using technology
so there there is always uh
a focus on the potential of blended
learning for example where
where we use technology to support
learning before and after a lesson
so so yes it's been part of what we do
for some time
it's not new it it's it's changed
because we've used it in a way which is
teaching online
i don't think anyone wants to make that
a habit
so i i'd hope we don't have modules on
how to teach on teams
because it's basically never as good as
really teaching in a classroom so let's
just stitch it yeah well adrian i have
to say
i share your will this would never
happen again but i have to say
that when the first lockdown happened i
thought that to myself as well i thought
now we've seen a huge harmless poses in
society
it's not going to happen again but it
did not twice i don't know once but
twice
again and martin perhaps like to throw
that that question to you because
during the pandemic a lot of teachers
were plunged into a position of using
tech
but they'd probably never seen before
now you'd have got some of the private
schools who probably had a lot more
resource to put into
training the teachers and how to do this
a lot of the um the
the lesser resource state schools will
have really struggled so do you think
this is
an issue because if there is it's not
impossible
to foresee not necessarily another
pandemic but school clotures for other
reasons
now this is a tool in policy makers
toolkit
i would be amazed if this never happens
again in my lifetime it'd be amazing it
doesn't happen again
sometime in the next five years so do
you think it's time martin that
that more was done to teach teachers
how to use tech properly when needs be
i i think it's a it's incredibly
important to teach them because if you
look
back over the history of um technology
and education in the last
i'd say sort of 30 years you can always
find
schools that are doing extraordinary
things with technology
and there are fantastic examples and
there have been fantastic programs and
there's been the evidence there about
the effectiveness of them but that
hasn't been
universal and a lot of schools have
fallen way way behind
and also that the training for teachers
has been um
so sporadic and it's on an individual
school basis and it's whether or very
very often just whether or not money was
left available in order to train
teachers
and i think going forward especially you
know after everything that we've been
through and this
experimentation with technology and also
i think with that
increase in confidence of teachers
because that was so often the problem
that teachers just don't feel confident
about teaching it
that we need as part of that wider plan
that i think we absolutely need
to think about how do we train teachers
to use that technology and also
to make recommendations about what
technology works
because you know if if you look at sort
of some of the programs that we have
you get data out of the back end that's
not just for the teacher you can gather
that because it's all available on the
platform and you can show whether or not
it's actually delivered the learning
outcomes that you wanted
now if that um evidence is available for
for for those programs then they ought
to be made available to all schools to
say look this has been
um in some way um uh you know there is
evidence that this works
and ensure that the teachers are
equipped to actually use that
so absolutely i think we need a huge
training program for all teachers around
this
for where it's needed well technology
has made today's events possible so
i'd like to and thank you for the gods
of zoom for making this possible thank
you for audience for joining us
and most of all and thank you to our
incredible panel
martin and and adrian and robert so if
you'd like to
ask any questions or here's the thing
right the question's gone but if there's
anything
you'd like follow up on anything you
think the spectator should be writing
about
raised from this discussion then please
do send an email to events at
spectator.co.uk we're going to be
writing lots about this
in the coming weeks and months and i
think it's all the more important
that these discussions happen outside
parliament because i don't think nearly
enough
as being said inside the parliament on
this hugely
important topic and again i'd like to
thank ever5 for
making this debate possible so thanks
for watching thanks to our guests
and and i would say join us next time
i'm not questioning when we'll have
another one of these but
i hope soon because it's there's so much
to learn
and perhaps we'll get that optimistic
outcome that adrian
mentioned in his opening remarks thank
you